oh yeah sorry i did the kid cudi oh
gamestop
this shit's at a hundred man it's at a
hundred
yeah yeah so gamestop so this is what
we're talking about yesterday it's like
unbelievable how global and how
short the news cycle is now why is it
like that everybody in the [ __ ] world
was talking about this [ __ ] on friday on
friday that was like
everyone i i've seen like tweets from
people that
have never traded a stock in their
goddamn life i guarantee it
talking about gamestop and gme everyone
was talking about it [ __ ] everyone
faze banks was
going off about it you know what i'm
saying
right like everybody was talking about
this
monday nobody i didn't see a single
tweet
two day three days later gamestop starts
going down everyone's like well guess
it's over no one talked
no one talked about it you know why bro
because between
friday and monday there's a 33 drop in
value when everyone checked their robin
hood account that monday morning
they're like they're like i don't know
if this is for me i'm out
yeah we're getting the billion
yikes holy
[ __ ] i gotta get out i got to get
out yeah yeah you guys hold the line i'm
out yeah yeah everyone else
but power to you hold that [ __ ] hold
that definitely hold the line i gotta
pay
the line yeah i mean it's
i don't know it dude do you know
man i just i i can't i can't wait to
read the posts
we i mean i tweeted this but i you know
it's so relevant
you know in a month how many
relationship advice po
advice posts are gonna be about my
husband
gambled away x amount you know our rainy
day fund on gamestop
yeah you know yeah my husband we're
gonna be doing some relationship advice
and posts about that for sure
it's gonna be really funny to see all
the dudes with on their burners
commenting well if you look at the chart
you know i don't know how many of you
trade stock but if you look at the chart
you know it'd be reasonable for him to
expect
to make some earnings okay here's why
and i can't believe they're making a
[ __ ] movie with noah centeno it's
like way to
ruin everything yeah netflix come on
what's the [ __ ] yeah we have to make
this applicable to teen girls
yeah get [ __ ] gamestop
noah centeno how do we get
teenage girls to give a [ __ ] about the
stock market
exactly that's what they talked about in
that meeting
okay the story is great i mean it's
happening in front of our eyes it's
unfolding it's an incredible story these
hedge funds
you know are going down finally after
what the financial markets did to us in
2008 finally we're getting our
redemption how can we make teen girls
relate to this though
dude i'm crying at a writer going
through all that
and then who in the room is like we have
to attach noah to this
nello sentinel i think he'd be great for
this he's
really got the chops for this did you
see him in the kissing booth three
he really [ __ ] he really showed his
range with that one i
think dude
okay also who's he gonna play deep
[ __ ] value
that's what i'm saying yeah he's gonna
be in his [ __ ]
apartment with the headband on yeah hey
fellow gamers i'm a nerd
that guy i'm a smelly nerd yeah that you
wanna [ __ ]
oh it's so hard being a stinky nerd
tracking stalks all day
i'm a stinky nerd that likes tendees
[Laughter]
they're gonna make him grow some like
patchy facial hair so he like looks a
little bit unkempt you know
he's still gonna be hot no what if noah
just goes full method
what if he just gets like fat fish yeah
just
gets out of shape gets thick grows an
uneven beard
he like he he forces himself to sit with
horrible posture for eight months
straight he's like that dude from south
park
yeah just yeah just crazy method and he
shows up to that movie everyone goes
oh my [ __ ] you know like when
christian bale did the mechanic
yeah yeah exactly yeah hey let's let's
get these attendees boys when are we
rolling
[Laughter]
yeah deep [ __ ] value looks like a
snitch
yeah what's what's his youtube kitty
roar
roaring kitty here uh yeah luke and kyle
pulled up some clips let's get here we
go
first of all okay i'm sorry go ahead go
ahead okay okay
no no go ahead
i was gonna um this is what he looks
like if he didn't know first of all
he should have stayed anonymous i don't
know why he did this but i guess it was
because he got doxxed
one of the news outlets like found his
real name
for somehow and published it and so he
kind of had no choice
but he should have [ __ ] stayed
anonymous right yeah like if he could
have
yeah definitely well dude
first of all i think this matching red
the red chair the headband the ar i hate
how like you know positioned this photo
is i even feel like the stack of uno
cards with
the red on them it's all just this
picture just seems too
put together okay you know i feel like
he's sitting on a set
i don't feel like this is his actual
dwelling right i don't know
i watched his videos the one where he's
got the game over
iron on is the one that made me think
he he's he's not a real person really
yeah i thought he was pretty charismatic
it was fun to watch
i was like this guy could definitely be
a youtuber if he wasn't
worth 30 million dollars now that's why
i think he's a plant dude
let's let's watch one of his clips who
planted them you think the hedge funds
yeah because they were actually long
game
kitty yeah they they knew what they were
doing
yeah yeah this guy bet you
okay let's see how robotic this guy
really is hey what's up everybody
welcome to roaring kitty this channel
revolves around live streams where i
share my daily routine of tracking
stocks performing investment research
and a whole bunch of boring stuff like
that
lately it just seems like there's been
heightened interest in the stock market
especially among investors new to the
industry right
and for these folks i'm thinking seeing
a legitimate investment process like
mine in action
day-to-day could help put you on the
right path to building on your own
little did he know pause for a second
little did he know what he did what he
put in motion
led instagram models to be
interested in the stock market more than
me somehow
that's what i mean by everyone was
tweeting about it literally everyone
in the world was buying gamestop stock
oh
i took screenshots of all the horrible
investment
takes from all kinds of people but
we can we can finish this
oh now i can lie we'll be doing some
boring stuff on this stream like
analyzing financial statements looking
at spreadsheets and charts and all that
i mean research is boring right but
maybe if it's more collaborative and
interactive maybe we could have some fun
with it you know
or maybe not what the hell do i know if
you're interested in something like this
check out the other videos on this
channel because they give you more
background on things like my investment
style and the tools i use and all that
wait positive
this guy's teaching a finance class to
to a college bro so it feels like
what it feels like to me is this dude
knows exactly what the [ __ ] he's doing
like dude this this what is this in like
his
fifth theater room in his big ass house
in new jersey or some [ __ ] like
it looks like he's cosplaying as a nerd
like on the other side of that are like
five [ __ ] investment bankers who are
like
they all live in the hamptons or some
[ __ ] and they're just listening
to him do his thing and they're just
giving him notes
no they're in the control room they're
controlling him
[Laughter]
you let this play hey what's up
everybody cheers happy friday happy
holidays i hope everyone's having a
great week
uh surprise game stops up
about 5x from when i uploaded those
videos over the summer so
that's great positive deposit luke this
is
exactly bro this is how you know
he he's been in this business for a
while because that 5x money
does not he doesn't give a [ __ ]
like there's no you know what i mean
like if one of us was like 5x on our
money like that i feel like
we'd start the stream and be like oh
yeah
yo i don't believe this [ __ ]
i'm rich yeah there'd be some element of
a [ __ ] game stop yeah i mean
if i can you know you'd be [ __ ]
bricks and this dude gets on he goes
you go uh you guys
um if you couldn't tell happy surprise
happy friday uh oh my gosh i'm a
5x jeez on this gamestop money thank you
guys so much and
in celebration i'm going to crack this
sudsy craft beer that i have here
because i also like dark craft beers is
he the mark wiens of finance
but yeah maybe maybe yo let it go a
little bit further luke
this and and by and large it unfolds as
you hope that it could
uh that's nice so it shouldn't be taken
for granted it doesn't always happen so
he's such a nice guy dude yeah it's uh
just to clear up
some potential misconceptions this this
was a true yolo for me
position last year we had nowhere close
to a million dollars
i certainly do not drive a lambo we rent
this house the juice that you see
so it's been a wild ride for us as a
family
and um and i i'm it has been just so
much fun
to experience that with you over the
past couple of months i hope you've had
uh some some fun as well and maybe if
you even picked up some educational
elements along the way all the better
but it has brought me tremendous joy
to to just share in this what has turned
out to be a bit of a case study right as
some of us feel
and it has brought me tremendous joy
[Music]
had a good time as well pause what if
at the end of this he just like rips
that shirt and there's a like a
perfectly pressed suit underneath
he just pulls a headband off that's why
at kitty roar financial
yeah i mean he's a really really nice
guy though he has
you can tell this guy's got a heart of
gold no i know i know he's not a plant
he's not a snitch he's just
you know but here's the thing though
he's too good of a guy he should have
gotten out
when he was 40 million up he should have
gotten out and
i don't care if you're like no what do
you mean he was the martyr like we
we were sticking to the hedge funds and
it was all because of him
yeah but i don't know like
apparently sorry go ahead no apparently
apparently he
is i guess maybe he said this somewhere
that he is
setting himself up so that he will exit
on eight figures
whether it's 10 or 40.
yeah but that's such a big difference i
know bro i know
it's huge but you know that
it was a true yellow for him so you know
i mean we're we're talking like yeah i
don't know it's like
you're holding the line for a group of
redditers i mean i guess it's
it is more than that now it's like a
movement amongst like everyone
right that to get back at like wall
street
for 2008 right but also like
generational wealth for your
family where you're like kids as kids as
kids as kids
will be fine you know i mean that's
pretty cool too yeah
well you know uh
yeah 40 million but 40 million to 10
10 million versus 40 million that's what
i'm saying it's like that's a couple
extra houses you know
yeah that's a that's a lot what does he
have at least what's
what's this one is he
the big short squeeze from five to fifty
most compelling asymmetric opportunities
in the market today
really i understand how you disagree
with that that's why it's the top
position in my portfolio and also dr
mike berry's portfolio
but based on prevailing sentiment the
market and popular culture many think
it's a foolish investment but everyone's
wrong
it's like the big shorty wait did he say
mike barry invested in that too yeah
really i guess the same guy that
was the first one to buy the short the
housing market
isn't that him i don't remember
that'd be crazy i don't know someone
please tell me if that's
if that's correct because that would be
[ __ ] insane anyways this guy knows
what he's doing and also
it is cool that he like actually had a
case for this stuff
yeah definitely no it's it's it's super
crazy i don't think it'll take
i don't want to take away from the work
that this guy has done you know this
shit's insane like a lot of them
actually like a lot of i watched some of
these and he like legitimately thinks
that
gamestop is gonna have like a resurgence
as a business so
like he's not totally betting on the
fact that
people are just like the the that he
could
rally up enough support for a short
squeeze he really thought that like
the fundamentals of the stock
uh the value was too low which is kind
of cool
which just legitimizes the whole thing
i'd be curious to know okay revitalizing
the in-store experience
yeah i'd be curious to know what his
thoughts are on why he thinks gamestop
would be a thing again
this man just people playing games
gaming together bro
that's you remember going to walmart and
like
standing up and playing one of those
like sample xboxes yeah for like an hour
in the blockbuster all that yeah that
[ __ ] all the time
there's like three snot-nosed kids
behind you waiting for a turn
can i can i please can i please
no yeah bro it's
my turn yeah let me see what we're
seeing still in 2020 gamestop maintains
a healthy market share within the gaming
industry
it's the only major brick and mortar
retailer we can pause this now
before we get too many people being like
um he has a point it is the only brick
and mortar retailer in gaming right now
yeah i mean so that whole thing's crazy
but it's also no one's talking about it
now
like everyone as of monday it was like
didn't see a single tweet about it
a couple billboards i saw got put up but
it was kind of like
people are over it people just get over
things so fast now
it's like okay i i spent my entire
friday reading about this
now it's now on to the next thing yep
well i almost feel that the news cycle
has been so
you know it's been so intense
at least the past year you know someone
dies
something political you know this this
and that that now people
you know the [ __ ] has to the the bar
for interesting is so high now yeah
it says every day is something new
that's what i mean yeah
but it's with the raising bar comes
uh like faster
uh i don't know you know getting over it
no yeah
return to i guess yeah we need like uh
we need a new cycle that's stays harder
longer
yeah like what we need we need what's
the gonna be the viagra for the news
cycle
it keeps it up keeps it interesting
it keeps it going you know yeah
you